hey guys it's justine and today we are
going on a field trip
my sister and i are getting a chance to
demo the all-new sony spatial reality
display a huge thank you to sony for
sponsoring this video and also hooking
us up with this incredible opportunity
to view this thing in person we got a
chance to interview tate mcrae who
worked with sony to produce an amazing
3d version of her hit song you broke me
first
this was the music video that we're
actually watching in this video on the
spatial reality display
it's 3d but i'm not wearing any glasses
so it's just like it's just happening
right in front of me
the facial reality display is an
entirely different experience
you don't even need glasses at all you
just look at it
and it works the display itself is a
15.6 inch lcd display that's covered
with a micro optical lens
that divides the image into the left and
the right eyes allowing for stereoscopic
viewing
and this is happening without glasses
with sony's proprietary
high speed vision sensor that's built
right into the top of the display this
will follow your eye movement
down to the millisecond sensing your
pupil position through space
vertically horizontally and even the
depth it's really hard to even explain
so when i move around from side to side
it's kind of
tracking my face so it's also moving
so when you're looking at the screen and
you're physically kind of moving around
it the display
will sense your movement and adjust the
content accordingly and this all happens
with a real-time rendering algorithm
that processes real time
in each eye it's really kind of
fascinating to just be sitting there
and staring at a display and it's
popping out at your face
it's almost like you can actually reach
out and touch it
it starts out in her bedroom and it's
cool because they completely did this
entire thing in 3d so they re-rendered
her entire room
they didn't even use motion capture for
this she basically filmed this
on her phone and they redid it in 3d
[Music]
it's so hard to even show you guys what
we were seeing
on the spatial reality display because
obviously you guys are watching this
here on youtube it's 2d you're not
seeing the 3d
experience that we were witnessing but
trust me when i say
that i was so impressed and just shocked
and i see so much tech on a day-to-day
basis that sometimes it's really hard to
feel excited and super impressed by
something and this was
honestly kind of mind-blowing to really
experience this in person so for
creators who are already kind of
creating this type of 3d content it's
very easy to integrate into your
workflow it's compatible with unity and
unreal engine 4 and you can just export
your
existing 3d content using sony's sdk the
music video that we were watching for
this demo is by an incredible artist
tate mcrae now what kind of made this
even more interesting
is we actually got a chance to talk to
tate to see what the whole process was
like
in creating this music video in
collaboration with sony
could you tell me
[Music]
oh my gosh tate i'm so excited that
you're hanging out with us here
virtually
how are you i'm great how are you doing
well yeah doing well can't complain
so okay when they told me that this
project was happening i thought it was
so cool because i
loved how in your music video you said
you shot it on your phone
taped your mom's car like that is
that is just that's talent right there
it was a process
i got i got sent home from new york and
i had to be home in two hours whatever
and i was releasing my song in like a
week
and they basically said tate you gotta
film a music video
but i was like uh what so
we literally just had to work with what
we got and it ended up looking actually
really cool but it was the process for
sure i yeah i was so impressed because
actually i watched it then i was
like reading the description i was like
oh my gosh she shot this on her phone
like that's incredible
yeah it was cool it was my friend and he
was driving backwards the entire time i
was like don't look at me please like i
can't you can't look at me as i'm
singing yeah what was that kind of like
going from
taping a phone to a car doing this crazy
3d project
well i mean the thing about this music
video was that it was it was really cool
it was on my phone but i felt like there
was also like a missing piece
when sony presents me with this idea
where they just literally wanted to
bring me to 3d i was like
ah sure i'm not going gonna do that but
sure and it was
crazy i i had no idea with this spatial
reality display that they could
take a mini tape and like literally
sculpt her into like this little
avatar it was the craziest thing to see
i had i honestly had no idea
what they were gonna put me into i was
just more honestly curious of how they
were gonna take my dancing and you know
make it into this 3d
thing it made me do full body scans like
i had to sit there for like 20 minutes
scanning my face
that's just crazy too thinking about the
technology like you were doing that from
a phone and sending that to them and
they were able to
to make this happen yeah it doesn't it
doesn't seem possible i mean i used to
edit
all my youtube videos and everything on
final cut pro and i thought that was the
extent of editing
she's a final cut editor i think we just
became best friends we are i'm so i've
been editing final cut i mean for a very
long time so like
whenever i find another final cut editor
i'm like oh my heart
is the best that's awesome that's so
cool though that you
also have like an editing background and
stuff like that too yeah i used to edit
all my videos and i used to really
i was like oh i'm so techy whatever and
then once i actually saw sony do their
thing it
kind of blew my mind basically like
you're gonna be one of the first people
kind of doing this like this is this is
exciting
it is exciting and honestly i never
really thought that i would be
collaborating with sony
it's just like a huge honor so it's
really cool
did you always want to do music or was
it more like dance focused
i always thought i was going to be a
dancer
like a backup dancer or something i
really just genuinely thought i was
going to be professional dancer because
i had no idea how to get into the music
industry
i loved writing and i loved singing but
i you just there was no
i you know you don't know how that works
i don't know how to didn't know how to
put myself out there
um and then i think when i started my
youtube channel it started to
obviously shift over a bit well you're
definitely not a backup dancer anymore
you're like i am the yeah
i'm doing it all i feel like for a lot
of
i mean it's like we also have like a big
female audience and i feel like you also
have a lot of girls that probably
are obviously looking up to you and like
man i really want to do that or maybe
not this specifically but something else
like do you have any advice for them
because like
even when i was growing up i never
really had like a role model that like
tech and stuff like that so now i feel
like there's so many like young girls
that are just like going for it yeah i
think that's the biggest thing is not
doubting yourself
and just putting yourself out there
that's what i had to do
just take a leap of faith and you know
fingers crossed see how it goes see how
people are going to react and then
after that just work as hard as you can
and
speak up that's all you can really do
you're so young and you've accomplished
so much so far so i just want to say
congratulations and
i'm just looking forward to you know
watching watching you blossom even more
in your in your upcoming career
thank you that means so much this is so
great i just think that you're a really
great inspiration too for
you know like our next kind of future
generation of girls because like we
really do need people like you that
you know these girls can look up to so
keep being awesome
and we're gonna we are gonna be right
there in front of the line
i mean actually maybe i'll even like
crowd surf can we do that i don't know
how we don't know how things work it's
true we'll figure it out whatever we can
do we'll be there doing it loud
loudly well thank you so much for
hanging out with us
so nice meeting you both after talking
with her and viewing the final music
video for you broke me first i was so
blown away with the production in the
final music video i also
really love talking to tate and hearing
her story if you guys want to get more
info about the display i'll put a link
in the description but this is really a
first look at the future of viewing
content this way
there are a few these displays out in
the wild and one of the places that you
can check it out in real life
in person to see really what it's all
about is at b h retail stores
i definitely look forward to the future
iterations of this because this really
is just the beginning if you guys
haven't subscribed to my channel be sure
to hit subscribe make sure you guys like
this video and i will see you guys
in the comments below and in my next
video
[Music]